I'm not sure where this is but it's in
China and it's a bad one but it's a boar
attacking an older man what a wild boar
in China and then the I'll just play the
video
don't be older like so check this why is
he killing them he just randomly came
out of that little forest area so this
is his daughter-in-law trying to save
him as well and then he just goes oh it
starts attacking her right now it's 220
pound beast was he trying to eat the
dread attacker all seriousness what do
you do here Oh shot by snipers yes here
oh this is a crazy wild war on the
ground man
dude that boar yes I am deadly the man
yeah but the lady did it no serious
injuries the holy [ __ ] what did it do
bite him and stuff no horn son got a
damage run - oh god damn what a terrible
way to go man 66 years old what's wrong
with that bull would you get on top of
it and choke it out I don't think so you
have to bro skins are so thick in that
situation you got to get on the back I
got an idea
I'm we going front like it just calm
down then you're gonna crawl up like
that hi in him bite his nuts well you
got to fight it off if he's attacking
you no look you're behind this is that
big old pours nuts yeah like this ah
and then he dies like the water buffalo
it's our only hope with your jagged
sharp teeth get right underneath and rip
his nuts off I don't I don't want to cuz
then he's gonna oh my god and they're
just us then it took a sniper to kill
you hundred twenty files you're bigger
than that so you have to it's on you to
fight that [ __ ] thing well I'm real
he's torn twenty pounds I'm not 240
that's hog strength that's hog muscle he
went down to the village because of snow
in the mountains I bombs to find food we
had died that sucks
damn I've never seen an actual boar
attack that was the first time I
actually saw a boar attack yeah everyone
talked about grouser nasty that's why
you have dogs hold him at bay when you
come in there and kill them with a knife
no I'm all about people kill them oh
yeah oh yeah and that was in 10th to run
at me
don't look at me soft like that bro
I'm saying we do well I did you
swallowing hard right now don't take big
sips out of straw how we do Wed have a
wet mouth on babies we do great I want
you to catch me man oh dude you're kind
of big and strong you would fall off
your shoes are just terrible you don't
know [ __ ]
what are those bro when I are Jordan
five bel-air Edition very hard to get
are they hard to get to are they that's
great you're pink and the purple was
bel-air Fresh Prince of bel-air main
game oh [ __ ] bro you don't know how
we're in the same great outfit oh
there's business socks oh there yeah
button up these are my sunglasses right
are you Einstein you put no effort no
life do you like to win same thing every
day
I don't know if an indoor soccer match
gonna break out I want to be ready
[ __ ] - Cudi crying great shoes
by the tamarillo last night giving me a
boxing lesson and and without gloves
actually hitting me in the stomach and
I'm like you you're hitting me in the
face
Frank's almost to aggro for me oh my god
I like to relax yeah well Frank will go
and box for an hour and a half when he's
in a city home he just crashes Jim's on
a bike goal be 763 with DC moving up to
heavy weight do you think we're all cold
we'll move up to light heavyweight if
this fight doesn't go his way or even if
it does yeah I think no matter what
happens so what I think through Rockhold
what happens I think he gets this win I
think he fights Whitaker no matter what
happens in that Whitaker fight he'll
move up to light heavyweight and he's
gonna be such a handful at light
heavyweight probably your world champion
light heavyweight especially wants DC's
gun gesturing could give some issue cuz
gustin's very similar but he's bigger
but I I think overall Luke Rockhold it
should be at light heavyweight and will
do very very very well there
I'm entering a lot of Kombucha from my
stomach I miss fancy new Kombucha I post
it last week it's Los angeles-based
give Amati whatever was that now that
was a team I'm down with that the tea I
was drinking I had sugar in it so I try
and stay away from sugar you know I'm
doing today after I leave here I mean
the valley at 2:30 to film a cooking
show with Bert Kreischer and Bryan
Callen
Burton has his up Bert Kreischer don't
cook yeah I think I saw something on
that on YouTube Oh silly that's awesome
yeah you sure make Aikido friendly meal
which I would just wish you to meet
something cool like a chili or some [ __ ]
I feel I feel like Bert should be making
chili like he'd be a beast of a chili I
mean I wish you'd let me cook those
burgers I'm telling you guys I make the
meanest cheeseburger this side of
[ __ ] Japan man Japan yeah that means
crosses a lot of goddamn land I make the
meanest burger ask anybody who's ever
had him when I would like when I close
in my house stuff when I get there I'll
have a housewarming party you come I'm
making the burgers that sounds freaking
awesome telling you I'm a beast at it
super beast I've been grilling since I
was a kid son it was like you know as
good as Rogen Rogen talk [ __ ] - yeah I'm
not making the fancy elk or moose
knuckle
dick sandwiches or the weird beer
intestines or whatever the hell he does
nah man I'm a goddamn American I make
the best cheeseburger ever you don't
make the Pacino cheeseburger I make the
pesto cheeseburger
steaks like fillets salmon ribs obese
men I don't know what my problem it's I
know I got a man one [ __ ] monster
grilling so one thing I can do right
guys it's the one thing I can grill so a
woman want that huge grand prize lottery
Wow four five hundred sixty million
little one of the things is you have to
you can't be a anonymous you have to
show your name so she's suing them to
try to make her name anonymous yeah
that's stupid why do you have to show
your name because I got a lawyer no I'm
saying that yes they should not show
their name all his family goes oh sweet
let us get your money they're gonna
figure it out when you go from living in
a [ __ ] trailer park to a goddamn
mansion and you know you just
disappeared like I took a new job yeah
yeah
and I actually the way I got out of here
is on my private [ __ ] jet ya see ya
helicopter I'm done with you bye
I got 500 600 you have [ __ ] you money no
not every close know not to [ __ ] you
money like I'm still a young guy I'm
young
ya don't get [ __ ] money you're
everywhere when you [ __ ] you money it's
a different what about you money the 20
mil in the bank that's that's [ __ ]
money I think yeah you need that [ __ ]
I know 20 mil it depends on your
lifestyle right Milford for the three of
us [ __ ] you money I don't know but I'm
not buying [ __ ] nine hundred ninety
five nine thousand nine hundred fifty
dollar Gucci jack see now is the time to
have [ __ ] you money when your your guys
age because you've had all the fun my me
I'm gonna go out and go crazy your age
gauge age what are you talking about bro
like you guys have lived like you like
to get the money and buy gold chains and
all your friends and maybe I'm gonna
have autologous cuz knowin you need a
little bit more cuz you wear those
[ __ ] boots and your Gucci che usually
just fender huh not really most of stuff
a lot of stuff you see I get for free
but I'm saying when you dress up like
when I saw you for the Grammys you had
that purple velvet jacket on I have a
stylist he takes hear that oh baby yeah
I mean you looked I was I was like whoa
do you know he is my man you attach it
there no let me see the Oscars the
Oscars I'm gonna give you hit it's
yellow what it's yellow it's yellow ish
it's gonna yeah he's a cutie-pie
he likes to dress up um I don't know
what would you do with 5:30 what would
that would that change your life if I
read 30 mil what would you do like let's
say you like you could like literally
live wherever you want but live in LA
you live in LA okay so you you'd buy
another home in LA yeah a pride pride
buy a home in Malibu buy place in
Hollywood just cuz when I'm like a like
an apartment right I just so I can chill
the pride buy a place in San Diego
that's about it you know you stay over
here like that you know you know I have
a chopper like Black Mamba so you know
the only thing I know is the the way I
travel I think Warren Buffett said that
to me too
I I hate the airports man
- such a sweet travels properly